a lot of the things that I felt like I
didn't think about it but now in
hindsight I can tell well I almost died
like one time I was at the I was at a
gas station I went to go pump gas for my
mom and I got held up at the gas station
I was able to talk myself out of it what
do you mean like just the person yeah
well the guy he he held me up and then
he had a gun pointed at me and then he
said give me your money and then I gave
him what I had in my in my wallet which
was eight dollars but in my pockets I
had 50 bucks and then the old pocket one
yeah and then he would suck I had 7 500
on he asked me for his for my wallet and
I said how are you gonna take my wallet
and I had a picture of the uh Virgen de
Guadalupe the Virgin the Mexican Virgin
Mary and I showed it to him I said I'm
gonna take this I know like and then
like what did he say and then he I he
looked at me and he he just went he
smacked my hand and he said man [__] you
and then he got in his car and then
but what I thought was I go you know
I know that was a loaded pistol like he
could have in hindsight I'd go yeah
totally he could have give him the
Virgin Mary yeah I should have just
given it to him you know what it was
though that wallet the stuff that was in
that wallet my Grandma had given to me
and she had recently passed yeah so I
was just kind of like I don't want to do
part with this you're making me realize
I've always thought I have like a clip
wallet that if somebody robbed me I
would try to remove the money yeah like
in like a David Copperfield because I
just don't want to replace all this yeah
what are you gonna do with my idea yeah
yeah what man I think it just it's
quicker you know give me your watch
that's where you're that bad and credit
card is or whatever right yeah so I feel
that that's can you believe you had the
wherewithal to be like come on man it's
my wallet I think I was so like in the
my Grandma had just passed so the minute
there was literally like a virgin Mary
little card photo she put in there and
now she gave it to you she gave it to me
so I was just like this I'm not going to
give you my [__] wallet you got my
money
and you're not because that's a bold
thing to say after handing it I mean I
should have just given him the 50 bucks
in my pocket you know if I wasn't even
thinking that right well the adrenaline
your heart had to be racing I mean we
can talk about it casually but nobody
with a gun pointed today is is uh
relaxing and then one time when I was 10
10 or 11 me and my friend this kid
Hector Soto we used to go to this comic
book store yeah you know Hector Soto it
was it was a comic book store on the
border between Inglewood and South
Central it was called the CBC the comic
book club this older like really sweet
older black nerd named Earl used to run
that company and
um
we were in there when it got robbed at
gunpoint and and the guy took money and
what was funny is he took a few comic
books too that were like on the wall I
don't think he's like expensive ones
yeah he just correlated with those are
expensive valuable and valuable and then
I you know he pointed the gun at us and
everything
in hindsight you know I I know now that
like in everything goes by so quickly
but I know in those situations he skip
he's not scared he's scared yeah and I'm
not saying that that he he I'm not
justifying his actions because he's a
show Person for doing this yeah of
course yeah but you're keeping in mind
that he's still a person yeah he does
there's a great Bruce Eric Kaplan
cartoon he dressed for the New Yorker
and it's a guy robbing a couple and the
you know the bank the robber you know
the bank robber the thief has a thought
bubble and it says God these things are
always so awkward yeah and I'm like what
I like about that cartoon is
he's not suddenly a thief he's some guy
yes I mean Steve yeah who likes this
type of ice cream and and took how many
poops did he poop that day yeah when did
he go to sleep and like what's his
favorite movie and then he goes in it's
not like Central Casting he's a guy yeah
and his heart is jacked and he's scared
and he's working he could get hurt yeah
all that sort of stuff yeah you can get
her and then so as I got older I
understood like oh man he could have
people die that way by accident yeah you
know by being scared yeah some you know
about what your cousin said yeah exactly
yeah exactly so those are the three that
come to mind I love that you're just
like those three times that I was at
gunpoint come to mind I'm like wow my my
question doesn't seem so cute anymore
have you ever almost almost bit it well
three or four times I was shot at okay
[Music]